so it's time for another video from my
visit with max Whitby the element
collector max makes real-life periodic
tables with real elements and the thing
I wanted to ask him was which elements
are the most difficult to collect and
display here's one of my favorites this
is osmium it's that one of the densest
elements arguably the densest element
it's an iridium kind of have battles
over which is denser but it it's around
about 22 grams per cubic centimeter so
very dense it's got a beautiful blue
color but you only see that blue color
when it's actually a solid metal and
pretty much the only way you can
actually buy osmium is as a powder and
so that powder has got two problems
first of all it's not very attractive
it's like a great powder could be
anything so you have to melt it very
high temperature and produce solid blobs
of it and then you can see it's
beautiful exquisite slightly blue color
I really love osmiums color the other
difficult thing about osmium is that it
oxidizes and that oxide or osmium
tetroxide is one of the most toxic
substances you can find in an inorganic
laboratory and just to give you some
idea the amount of osmium that's here if
it was oxidized and produced osmium
tetroxide could potentially harm
thousands of people let me give you
another example you'll be familiar with
the marvelous fluorine gas you could
almost say this is a logically
impossible element sample to display
since it attacks every known substance
and just about the only thing that will
keep it contained is dry scrupulously
dry quartz so what we've got here is a
quartz ampule that's been heated to just
under the melting point of quartz and
then filled with very low concentration
of fluorine I kind of think there might
be a few molecules of fluorine left here
but between you and me the likelihood is
that they will actually by now because
this was made a year or two ago they
will probably have attacked the glass
but what we've tried to do is our very
best to produce a sample of fluorine and
more than you do then a third element
that is quite a challenge actually just
a challenge to obtain is thorium again
radioactive element so it's encased in
solid block of acrylic there's about
half a gram here well one of the
problems with thorium is simply
obtaining it and there are now very very
few places in the world where you can
buy any even laboratory suppliers don't
sell it
III I guess because of its association
with nuclear technology that probably
was a systematic campaign by the world's
authorities to make it unobtainable and
so we found it one of the most difficult
elements to source in the periodic table
another problem is that you need a
pretty heavy-duty license to send it out
of the country we discovered this when
we had a knock on the door one morning
and some nuclear police came and asked
us some questions and we've been really
careful to read through this delightful
book which is the dangerous goods
shipping regulations all thousand pages
of it and we made sure that when we sent
thorium we followed exactly i otters
instructions you know we got training
and ended exams but it turns out that in
order to send thorium outside the UK to
Australia which is the country that
shocked us I hope you don't know any
Australians you need a license and so
now when we send send the samples
overseas we have to apply it takes a
couple of months lots of forms to fill
in and even for half a gram of thorium
you need an export license francium is a
difficult element there's probably at
any one time only a few milligrams or
micrograms on the planet earth and the
way we provide it is as a small lump of
uranium ore and if you do the analysis
there is an obscure side branch of the
uranium decay chain which means at any
one time there is likely to be an atom
or two francium in that sample so I
wouldn't say you could actually see any
francium but at least you know there is